my neck mom I'm just a single mother
looking for wha
the escape room click on an object
ooh I need a screwdriver oh I picked up
a secret code okay go to door okay Wow
virtually impossible but in what way let
me do a sick flip into death let's try a
sick flip again [ __ ] move well here
we go shopping - shopping - shopping -
ow - a boo-boo
oh that was easy oh hello where are we
going why are we going backwards now son
I think you might need to prepare
yourself from some immediate death
happening because I have a funny feeling
is to balance on the front wheel I think
okay wait wait wait wait wait Tetris is
dangerous Oh No
what's gonna happen to me am I going to
survive let me just a little lay down on
this Tetris block over here nothing's
gonna get me am i safe up here I have a
funny feeling it'll be okay so far so
goo we hel how highs it's gonna build up
my butt is vulnerable on that right now
oh god wait a minute some doesn't seem
fair about this
I wish you didn't stick my butt out so
much well I guess I don't need to worry
about the butt problems anymore
whoa I forgot that's a trickster well I
have so much more maneuverability now
okay we're good
wait we're not good huh oh ho got out of
that sit yep
backflip into survival somebody oh oh
not my butt whoa just back away be
inflatable arm-flailing tube-man somehow
all right
ooh is that a way out Oh God oh wait
yeah I just got to be Oh get up again so
why did you betray me with boo-boop
don't know no well I leave life is fine
and dandy
you ready primed and ready whoa get back
get back get back so I gotta wait for my
opportunity
there it is that's what I was waiting
for that's what I was slapping on okay
dodge this way huh
okay dodge back bring it back make that
ass clap what are you doing no oh god no
no no no no that sounds like mines and
bombs huh
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine no
God tits [ __ ] okay I think we're good I
think we're good
like we knew that we would go [ __ ]
forward you this is an endeavour [ __ ]
[ __ ] asses whoa no no no [ __ ] off get
out just [ __ ] are you [ __ ] why why no
no no no no no no [ __ ] you
okay got it okay just just [ __ ] okay
yes okay yes
the level title was ninjas only oh if
this has anything to do with FarmersOnly
I'm gonna have a good time
Oh kids I don't think there's right Oh
kitties
cheating [ __ ] I'm still cheating [ __ ]
all of you Pogo man Pogo man [ __ ] Pogo
man oh you thought you had me but the
answer was you somehow got me ow
just need to spear my butthole and that
400 going badly for us oh [ __ ] okay all
right back there huh
you're doing fine Whoopie whoo ah [ __ ]
you
ww-wha [ __ ] hang on wait Oh get ready
for the double under turn over [ __ ]
you're ready for the ass blaster nine
ready for the the fondle baller you're
ready for the [ __ ] inspection can you
just take a good look you're ready for
get ready for the pacifist you're ready
for the pacifist you ready for the
unpleasant 69 for the awkward Dorse
[ __ ] you're ready for Jeff
Goldblum's kiss Oh get get ready for the
tender loving embrace
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye